>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi sẽ tạo ra tôi sử dụng một chức năng tuyệt vời, nhưng
chúng tôi gọi đối tượng này là bản sao đơn lẻ hoặc đơn lẻ, tôi thậm chí không muốn chúng tôi là bản sao của
bài hát đó không phải là một phiên bản giống nhau của mỗi chức năng của chúng tôi.
Và chúng tôi sẽ chạy Tôi sử dụng một chức năng sáng tạo, nó sẽ tạo ra các đối tượng
bên trong bằng cách sử dụng tạo đối tượng, đây chỉ là một cách khác để tạo đối tượng. dddd
Nhưng các đối tượng đó bằng cách nào đó sẽ có liên kết của chúng ta với đối tượng lưu trữ hàm người dùng đó.
Có nghĩa là, khi đối tượng đó được trả lại cho người dùng, một đối tượng có
thuộc tính của nó, nhưng không có chức năng nào được lưu trên nó
Khi chúng tôi kết thúc sử dụng đối tượng đó, sử dụng tăng một chấm và nó không tìm thấy
gia tăng trên đối tượng, chúng ta sẽ hoảng sợ Nó sẽ có một liên kết bằng cách nào đó tới
sử dụng một cửa hàng chức năng nơi nó sẽ tìm thấy phương thức gia tăng và sử dụng nó.
Tất cả mọi người, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Dòng một.
Jeff, chúng ta đang làm gì trong bộ nhớ toàn cầu?
Chúng ta đang làm gì vậy?
>> Jeff: Chúng tôi đang khai báo một hàm người dùng đã tạo.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, trong bộ nhớ toàn cầu, người dùng,
người sáng tạo, >> Will Sentance: Đây rồi.
Các chức năng cũ, tuyệt vời.
Bây giờ, cho Matt.
>> Matt: Chúng tôi sẽ xác định một cửa hàng hàm người dùng không đổi-
>> Will Sentance: Vâng.
>> Jeff: Với một giá trị >> Will Sentance: Của một đối tượng.
>> Matt: Của một đồ vật.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, đừng để bị bắt người,
ở đây trong suy nghĩ nó là bất cứ điều gì khác.
Đó là một đối tượng, vâng.
Đây rồi.
Vâng, và những gì được lưu trữ trên đối tượng?
>> Matt: Chúng tôi có thuộc tính gia tăng và thuộc tính đăng nhập.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, và đó là một phương pháp gia tăng vì hàm của
được lưu trữ trên đó.
Và một Thuộc tính đăng nhập cũng là một phương thức.
Chà, cánh tay của tôi thực sự bắt đầu đau nhức.
Đi thôi.
Không vấn đề gì.
Đây rồi.
Cảm ơn bạn rất nhiều.
Bây giờ chúng ta chuyển sang slide tiếp theo bên tay trái.
Braden, nói gì để làm?
>> Braden: Khai báo hằng số người dùng-1.
>> Jeff: Người dùng-1.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng ta có biết những gì nó hiển thị ở đây không, mọi người.
Không, chúng tôi phải đi và điều hành chúng tôi, người sáng tạo, tất cả mọi người hoàn toàn mới.
>> Học sinh: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Bối cảnh hành quyết, đẹp.
Điều đó thật sôi động để vượt qua
đối số sẽ và ba thực thi hoàn toàn mới
ngữ cảnh như bạn đã nói >> Will Sentance: Vì vậy
tuyệt vời, nó đây.
Không, nó đây.
Được rồi, chúng tôi
đi, >> Jeff: Tôi
không làm được là bộ nhớ cục bộ chúng tôi có, >> Jeff: Được rồi
việc đầu tiên chúng ta xử lý, với Dan, chúng ta sẽ xử lý việc gì trước?
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi gán Will cho tên đối số.
>> Jeff: Gần như, tranh luận về Ý chí đối với- >> Câu nói Di chúc: Xin lỗi,
vào tên tham số.
>> Jeff: Tên thông số, vâng, chính xác.
Và tham số tiếp theo là điểm, chúng ta gán vào đối số nào?
>> Di chúc: 3.
>> Jeff: 3, đẹp.
Rất vui, cảm ơn Dan.
Bây giờ chúng ta nhập phần thân của hàm, nơi toàn bộ điểm của hàm này
Nhân tiện, hãy tạo một đối tượng với dữ liệu của một người dùng cụ thể được lưu trữ trong đó và
chức năng sẽ từng được áp dụng cho người dùng cụ thể đó.
Đó là điểm duy nhất.
Vậy chúng ta phải làm gì trong dòng tiếp theo?
Kyla, chúng tôi tạo ra một?
>> Will Sentance: Một người dùng mới liên tục.
>> Jeff: Vâng, và gán cho nó >> Will Sentance: Đối tượng trống.
>> Jeff: Một vật thể rỗng.
Xin lỗi.
>> Will Sentance: Với thuộc tính của user function store.
>> Jeff: Không có thuộc tính, nó thực sự là một đối tượng rỗng.
Nhưng tôi sẽ nói rằng tôi đồng ý, bằng cách nào đó nó đã
một liên kết mật thiết giữa đối tượng này
đang được tạo Và tôi sử dụng cửa hàng chức năng.
Chúng tôi vẫn chưa biết làm thế nào nhưng có một liên kết mật thiết.
Được rồi, nhưng chúng ta hãy phù hợp với các thuộc tính đó.
Dan, thực ra, Adam, xin lỗi về điều đó.
Không phải lúc nào tôi cũng nên ghi rõ nó ở phía sau, Adam.
Tiến lên.
Chúng tôi có một đối tượng người dùng mới.
Chúng ta sẽ thêm ngay vào nó những gì?
>> Will Sentance: Một tài sản được gọi là tên.
>> Jeff: Vâng, và?
>> Will Sentance: Và gán lại giá trị của nó cho tên đối số, đó là Will.
>> Jeff: Tuyệt vời, và sau đó?
>> Will Sentance: Điểm là 3?
>> Jeff: Vâng, hoàn toàn ổn, đối tượng đó.
Chúng ta làm gì với nó?
Đó dường như là những gì chúng ta cần.
Nó có dữ liệu và nó được liên kết bằng cách nào đó với các chức năng của chúng tôi, nhưng
nó bị kẹt bên trong bối cảnh thực thi của chúng tôi.
Matt, làm thế nào chúng ta lấy nó ra.
Chúng tôi sẽ trả lại đối tượng chính xác thành nhãn toàn cầu Matt,
sử dụng một trong những tuyệt vời.
Và nó ở đó với tên: Will,
điểm: [SOUND] 3.
Và bất kỳ phương pháp gia tăng nào trên đó?
Chính xác, nhưng bằng cách nào đó nó có một liên kết tới bộ sưu tập các hàm ở đây.
Chúng tôi sẽ xem cách nào trong giây lát, đừng lo lắng.
Được rồi, chúng tôi đã trở lại toàn cầu, chúng tôi tuyên bố bây giờ là người dùng hai.
Nó sẽ là kết quả của một cuộc gọi khác tới người dùng, một cuộc chạy khác,
một bối cảnh thực thi khác để chạy trình tạo người dùng.
Lần này với lập luận của Tim, và năm.
Đầu ra của nó sẽ là gì?
Tôi sắp bỏ qua bối cảnh thực thi,
biết rằng chúng tôi đã đi vào bên trong và làm tất cả.
Vậy rốt cuộc chúng ta sẽ làm gì ở đây, Matt,
tất cả đầu ra được lưu trữ vào người dùng 2B?
>> Will Sentance: Đối tượng có tên thuộc tính với giá trị của Tim.
Đó là thuộc tính, điểm của giá trị 5 và một liên kết không thể xóa được.
>> Jeff: Vâng, một liên kết bí ẩn không thể xóa được, thông qua?
>> Will Sentance: Kho chức năng người dùng.
>> Jeff: Thông qua cửa hàng chức năng người dùng.
>> Will Sentance: Nhìn này, họ đã hợp nhất tốt, ở đó.
Và bạn đang thông qua cửa hàng chức năng người dùng.
Được rồi, bây giờ chúng ta kiểm tra.
Chúng ta sẽ làm, hãy làm user1.increment,
đó là những gì tôi có ở đây, user1.increment.
Todd, bạn đã biết, nó kết thúc với bạn.
Todd, JavaScript sẽ đi đâu khi tìm kiếm user1?
>> Jeff: Trong bộ nhớ toàn cầu.
>> Liệu Sentance: Bộ nhớ toàn cầu, chúng tôi tìm thấy nó?
>> Jeff: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, chúng tôi làm, chờ đợi.
>> Will Sentance: Có, chúng tôi làm.
Chúng ta đang tìm kiếm gì ở đối tượng đó?
>> Jeff: Sự gia tăng.
>> Will Sentance: Increment, chúng ta có tìm thấy nó không?
>> Jeff: Không phải ngay lập tức.
>> Will Sentance: Không, nó không nằm trên đối tượng đó.
Chúng ta có bỏ cuộc không?
>> Jeff: Không.
>> Câu Tiễn: Ta theo tím về đâu?
>> Jeff: Liên kết không thể xóa được.
>> Will Sentance: Liên kết không thể xóa, lên đến?
>> Jeff: Chức năng người dùng.
>> Will Sentance: Chức năng bị đánh cắp ở nơi chúng tôi tìm thấy trên đó-
>> Jeff: Sự gia tăng.
>> Will Sentance: Tăng dần, và chúng tôi lấy mã của nó.
Và những người mà chúng tôi sẽ bắt đầu hành quyết trong giây lát.
Vì vậy, tôi muốn tất cả các bạn thấy một số điều thú vị về chức năng đó mà chúng ta cần
đảm bảo là đúng.
Bởi vì chức năng đó sẽ có thể được sử dụng trên người dùng 1, trên người dùng 2, trên người dùng 400.
Trước khi làm điều đó, hãy hiểu cách thức liên kết này thực sự được lưu trữ.
Nó được tạo bằng auto.create.
Bất cứ điều gì bạn chuyển vào, chúng tôi sẽ nhận được liên kết không thể xóa nhòa, liên kết đó.
Nó được lưu trữ như thế nào, đối tượng, chụp lại,
object.create không tạo ra một đối tượng trống, tôi đứng đó.
Và Kayla đang gợi ý, hãy nắm chắc cách thức liên kết này được tạo ra?
Vâng, cô ấy đúng khi nói điều đó, là một cái gì đó sẽ xảy ra.
Nhưng nó nằm dưới mui xe mà chúng ta không thể nhìn thấy nó.
Khi chúng tôi đến bảng điều khiển, tôi sẽ chỉ cho bạn cách thực hiện sau một giây.
Một thuộc tính ẩn trên đối tượng này.
>> Will Sentance: Và đó là một câu chuyện hài hước, nó được gạch dưới kép,
proto double gạch dưới, họ gọi đó là proto dunderscore hoặc
dunder, proto dunder, proto property,
và nó đã được lưu trữ trong đó hoặc liên kết đến.
Kho chức năng người dùng.
Không không không không.
Trả lại đối tượng đó vào người dùng 1 và
đằng sau hậu trường, nó vẫn có
liên kết proto tới kho chức năng của người dùng.
Liên kết proto này, kết nối chuỗi này từ người dùng 1 đến cửa hàng chức năng của người dùng.
Và nó cũng ở đây.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi có một giới thiệu, một liên kết,
thực sự sẽ thấy được viết ở đây.
Kho chức năng người dùng, một liên kết đến đối tượng đó.
Có nghĩa là, hãy bắt đầu, Braden.
Braden, nếu tôi đang sử dụng user1.increment, hãy nói chuyện với tôi.
Tôi tìm người dùng ở đâu?
Chúng ta sẽ tìm thấy nó?
>> Jeff: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Đúng vậy.
>> Will Sentance: Cái này không hoạt động,] Tôi thấy nó có, tôi làm.
Tôi tìm kiếm phương pháp tăng dần trên đó.
Tôi có tìm thấy nó không?
>> Jeff: Không phải ngay lập tức.
>> Will Sentance: Không, nhưng JavaScript làm được gì?
Tôi thực sự sẽ nói với bạn, JavaScript có nó khá nổi bật,
tính năng nguyên mẫu.
Điều đó có nghĩa là khi nó không tìm thấy trên đối tượng A thuộc tính đã cho,
phương pháp hoặc dữ liệu nó không hoảng sợ.
Thay vào đó, nó đi thẳng đến thuộc tính __proto__ không phải là
nhầm lẫn với nguyên mẫu.
Bạn thấy đó là sai lầm.
Vì vậy, nó là thuộc tính __proto__ và nó xem xét những gì đang liên kết đến,
và đang liên kết với proto Lên chuỗi nguyên mẫu,
nhưng vâng, lên chuỗi nguyên mẫu thì không sao cả.
Lên chuỗi nguyên mẫu hoặc
hãy nói thông qua liên kết tham chiếu proto của nó đến nơi Bradon.
>> Jeff: Chức năng người dùng- >> Will Sentance: Kho lưu trữ chức năng người dùng.
Chúng ta tìm thấy gì?
>> Jeff: Sự gia tăng.
>> Will Sentance: Phương pháp tăng dần, và chúng tôi lấy nó Và
chúng tôi tạo một bối cảnh thực thi hoàn toàn mới cho mã của nó.
Tôi sẽ đến điều đó trong giây lát.
Nhưng bây giờ chúng ta hãy thích mô hình này khi mọi người nhìn,
Nó không đẹp sao?
Người dùng này 1, người dùng này 2.
Không ai trong số họ có các bản sao riêng lẻ của các chức năng của chúng tôi, nó sẽ hoàn toàn
dư thừa như một sự lãng phí không gian bộ nhớ.
Chúng tôi thực sự giỏi trong một vấn đề.
Mã đó được lưu trong bộ nhớ và các bản sao của nó vì nó lãng phí không gian bộ nhớ.
Thay vào đó, chúng tôi có thông qua tài sản chuyên nghiệp để ẩn hoặc
liên kết đến một bản sao duy nhất hoặc tới một đối tượng duy nhất, nơi tất cả những
các chức năng chúng ta muốn tất cả các đối tượng này có quyền truy cập được lưu trữ.
Và đó là bản chất nguyên mẫu JavaScript mà các đối tượng khi chúng ta nhìn vào chúng
một phương pháp mà chúng tôi không từ bỏ và chúng tôi không tìm thấy nó.
Đầu tiên chúng ta kiểm tra thuộc tính proto và đi đến đối tượng đó.
Đó là nguyên mẫu của nó là một trong những tính năng là một tính năng giống như phạm vi từ vựng của nó
thuộc tính là một tính năng giống như bộ nhớ chung của nó.
Giống như một tính năng.
Đó là một tính năng mà các đối tượng có kết nối với các đối tượng khác nếu chúng ta đặt chúng
để làm như vậy thông qua thuộc tính proto của họ.
Và khi JavaScript tìm kiếm thứ gì đó và đối tượng không tìm thấy nó,
nó xảy ra lỗi ngay lập tức.
Nó đi và kiểm tra một lớp hoặc có thể nhiều hơn.
Chúng ta sẽ thấy trong giây lát.